[Music]
hi and welcome to episode number 53 of
the weekly Google cloud platform podcast
I am Francis Campo and I'm here with my
colleague mark Mendell hey Mark how are
doing I'm doing all right I'm getting
over the flu a little bit but otherwise
I seem to be doing reasonably well how
you doing uh pretty scare about sharing
a small recording studio with someone
with a flu but other than that for it
it's fine you did it last week I would
yeah I should be fine and very excited
about holidays to be honest yeah but yes
yeah my indoctrination into the American
culture continues as I partake in
Thanksgiving soon fans gave me a
friendsgiving and all the kind of
versions of Turkey yes lots of food so
today we have a summer for our team we
have a jam early yep and we're going to
be talking everything Ruby the beautiful
prom in language and how you can do cool
things on the club with it yeah it's
really cool we're going to see some
really awesome stuff that google cloud
has been doing with Ruby yeah it is one
of these episodes where I'm excited
about it because I don't know much about
Ruby really like f I brilliant some
lines of code yeah we'll be in had fun
but never wrote anything real so I'm
very excited about as you're telling us
a little more about me it's been a while
since I've written review actually and
then we have a question of the week
which is about one of our favorite
favorite all-time topics Cooper Nettie's
yeah we're going to talk about how you
can manage things if you want certain
pods or containers to run on particular
nodes inside your cluster yeah something
that makes total sense in a couple cases
there yep you know you have a one of the
machines is bigger or you have license
constrictions constrictions is that I
were in strange restrictions or
constraint that works direction I just
create the word constrictions you're
like it we should use it for now yep
yeah but before that we we have to cool
things of the week and one of them I'm
so excited about it because it is
actually something we've been waiting
for quite a while I know a lot of people
that were asking for it many customers
yep and we have it a GPUs yeah we
finally announcing that we're going to
have GPUs in early 2017 available on
Google Cloud it's been a
long time coming yeah and and it's good
for amazing I mean especially for you
like you do a lot of like video games
and rendering stuff like that like that
it's going to be huge yeah I mean we've
had rendering pipelines on google cloud
for a while but GPUs are definitely
going to help out which is going to be
really awesome yeah I'm very excited
about it and to see basically old all
the cool things that people are going to
be able to make with this and all the
math people who are going to be able to
do very fast calculations and then can
have a mess this is fine just kidding
that it's very important to the second
cool thing of the week is about Google
Cloud joining the dotnet foundation yeah
I think this is super cool as well
really I feel like Google cloud is
really kind of hate to use the phrase
doubling down is really focusing on net
and windows as a really core platform
for google cloud i'm really excited by
the things going on in the space and i
think this is just kind of another sign
of that yeah i mean it was just a couple
weeks ago that we had the episode about
dominate and my own windows on Google
cloud platform maybe it's a good time to
listen to it again there's lots of work
on that side of the total thing so go
check it out definitely well it sounds
like it might be time to go have a chat
with Azure about Ruby sounds good letter
that sounds good so I'm absolutely
delighted do you have a jackhammer lay
back with us again in the podcast booth
how are you doing today Asia I'm having
a good damn excited to come talk to you
guys excellent excellent in case people
hadn't talked to you either conferences
or events or listen to the podcast
before do you want to tell us a little
bit about who you are and what you do
okay I'm a developer advocate on the
Google Cloud team and my to my primary
focus is on DevOps networking security
operations monitoring logging all that
kind of stuff but my passion is Ruby and
I've been part of the Ruby community for
tennis years at this point and I'm
really glad that I get to talk a little
bit today about what Google is doing
with through because that's what I'm
spending some of my time on cool and for
those that are interesting on interested
on your other passion we actually had
you before we had you and have it right
in front of me july 13 so that was
episode 34 talking about monitoring and
select driver so if you're interested
about that go check it out and today
instead we're going to be talking just
ruby one hundred percent
I'm so excited cool all right so we're
talking about Ruby the language I guess
then why Ruby why are we talking about
this so the Ruby community is
surprisingly big a lot of people don't
realize how big it is it's being taught
in a lot of boot camps and there's a lot
of relatively large websites that are
running it I think my favorite example
is github which most of us use nearly
every day is got a fair amount of Ruby
internally cool and it's a huge market
there's a lot of stuff and we're trying
to figure out as part of cloud platform
how can we support our developers butter
and one of those ways is we can support
the languages they're using and meeting
them where they're at and so I've been
part of our cloud Ruby effort over the
last couple months as we're trying to
beef up our libraries beef up our
support for Ruby and make it a place
that rubios feel comfortable cool so why
then you tell us a little bit about what
kind of things have you been working on
so our two big projects right now or
we're writing our Google Cloud libraries
being released as Ruby gems and more and
more coming out nearly every day on a
regular basis all this is being done in
the open it's all on github and there
are Google cloud platform project and
the other thing we've been working on is
Ruby support and rails support for App
Engine flex we also support Sinatra the
other big web framework for Ruby and I'm
really happy with where that's at I
actually got to participate in a
hackathon with it last week and I
deployed a couple of my personal
projects my side projects to the
platform and it was awesome it was great
that they came up real quickly I got to
see everything in place hooked it into
cloud sequel no no issue at all just had
to get the right IP address in the right
files and it was really awesome having
something that was that so that's
seamless and not easy on our platform
because when I started two years ago we
didn't have a ton of Ruby support and so
seeing that transformation of the time
being able to talk to my community at
events like Reba conf about the cool
stuff we're doing it's been really
exciting and they're excited to hear it
too awesome so I guess that means yeah
so you've got the support there for the
frameworks and the tools that are the
comment of the Ruby community to be able
to deploy your stuff as well as all the
SDKs and tools and gems I guess to
interact with all our back-end services
like storage and like all there are
other things yeah I'm actually been
really excited we're doing a bunch of
examples work right now and flushing out
the MLA pis i did a cool talk at rails
using the vision API to do kind of a
where in the world is Carmen Sandiego I
think that might have been your idea
mark that I stole that is it pretty
awesome ABS so we use the vision API to
recognize landmarks and we used it to
recognize we did text speech to text
with translate with a sign that was in
Japanese we used it to recognize various
other things we did some geocoding based
on where landmarks were and we did it
all in Ruby and it was really fun and
the fact that I was able to do that all
in ruby was great and the community has
been great we've been getting community
contributions back to our examples repo
which I'm super excited about because
that means the community wants to help
us and pull requests welcome so it's
been it's been fantastic and then we
have support now also for visions out
we're working on translate we've got
support for speech coming out or in the
in-flight at least and all this is
happening on github so you can easily
see what's working what's being worked
on at any given time it's been fun and
Ruby doesn't have a ton of ml root the
Ruby community in the ml community don't
overlap a huge amount and so being able
to bring these tools and do these people
in a way that is really simple to use
has been great because pulling in huge
ml libraries like see libraries and
stuff and then trying to link them into
Ruby is kind of a pain whereas the cloud
the cloud ml library is just an API call
something that we already know and
that's been great cool so i'm not i'm as
you know i'm not a rubios so it tells
them to be more about like how is the
experience of like if you were a ruby
developer that has done like ruby apps
let's say web apps on other platforms or
maybe locally what is the experience of
moving that to the cloud so this is the
part I like the best once you figure out
the database piece and you can run your
if you're going to use flex you can run
your database and cloud sequel you can
run it as a separate instance you can
use data store once you figure out the
database piece and doing that's actually
pretty straightforward you just go in
and edit the standard file that you
would edit to change to your production
database configuration or just edit your
production database configuration you
type G cloud app deploy and it goes nice
and it asks is this a ruby up and you
say yes this is in fact a ruby app and
it goes and the defaults work for the
vast vast majority of application
and the other nice thing is that a lot
of our libraries have been written by
hand and so there's a lot of stuff that
just feels natural my favorite example
is our bigquery library so bigquery is
the database product and if you go into
co create a new table in bigquery using
the ruby library use a syntax that is
nearly identical to the syntax he used
to write migrations and rails the same
kind of block format and the first time
i did i'm like wait I know this it was
that moment for jurassic park again but
we do that in other places the vision
API one of the kind of things in ruby is
there's always more than one way to do
things it's kind of anti python that way
yet although the communities are largely
overlapping and syntax looks similar a
lot of the time and the vision API has
four or five different methods to send
out a request even though it's only
actually one vision endpoint and the api
on google side and that just feels
natural because i can ask it for
landmarks or i can ask it for faces or i
can ask it for labels and it's sending
the same sending a request it's the same
request out but i can actually get the
data that i want in that situation so
that's been fun if i remember correctly
you made a video that long ago boho to
make big crate tables with Ruby yeah
I've been working on a new video series
as part of our cloud minute that's using
Ruby we did making a big query table we
did uploading a picture to cloud storage
I used a lovely picture of a mountain
goat from a hike i took recently it was
fantastic and we've also been doing some
videos with some of the community
libraries fog is the cloud multi-cloud
provisioning and deployment type library
for ruby it supports eight of us that
supports Rackspace it sports a lot of
stuff and do several folks at Google now
are who are working on improving cloud
fog Google and I've been doing demos
with fog Google showing how you can use
the tools that you're probably already
using to interact with our platform in
addition to the platforms you might be
using where the stuff you might be more
familiar with cool I think that it
there's a question we went over it real
quick you mentioned the data store or
cloud sequel in case people don't know
what is the difference could we talk a
little bit about like in terms of a
rubios what is datastore so data stores
are no sequel database in Google at
Google and to be honest I don't know a
ton of folks who are using
no sequel with rails I'm sure there are
some in fact we talked about that a
couple minutes ago before we started it
several several of us have done that at
various points but a cloud sequel is our
hosted my sequel and it's just a drop in
replacement you can use the exact same
my sequel gem that you use and you just
pointed out the correct host I was die
PE that we give you and it just works
it's great and then if you want a lot of
rubios like postgres i like postgres and
if you want to run postgres you can
totally run postgis on a Google compute
engine instance and manage your own
postgres instance if you want i know we
also have like deployment manager you
can through through the cloud launcher
you can deploy postgres that latin works
out quite nicely cool so you basically
just click once deployed that's it
that's it nice so I know you do a lot of
stuff on the monitoring side there any
hooks there for monitoring of like rails
app so Ruby apps as well so we've got a
team we've actually built a really fun
Ruby team in Seattle there's four or
five of us who work on Ruby on a regular
basis including several devs who are
working full time now and one of the
things they're doing is they're making
stackdriver integration libraries for
rails and Ruby I believe the logging
library went out last week and the rest
of them are in progress and this is all
again on github under the Google cloud
platform g-cloud Ruby project so you can
see our progress you can see what issues
have been entered obviously we're going
to have some integrations with other
parts of the system grp see libraries
and things like that and so if there's
particular issues you're running into
you can see if someone else has reported
it and how close we are to fixing it so
you've mentioned a little bit about the
things that you've been working on and
what's coming up bree olson uh what else
is coming up what is what are you
excited about and that other rubyists
might be excited about on google phone
so I'm actually really excited about the
fact that we just recently had the App
Engine flex beta 2 and that App Engine
flux is getting very very stable and
starting to look really good in Ruby we
have some platform as a service options
but always having more is great as I say
for pretty frequently when people ask me
to compare various providers they're all
different but competition it helps
everyone because everyone's pushing the
envelope making the experience better
and setting a higher bar for how
developers get to interact with these
tools so I'm really excited about App
Engine flex
I'm also excited that we're doing some
automatic automatic code generated
libraries for some of the api's that we
haven't gone around to yet haven't
gotten around to doing the hand coding
on and those are happy I'm happy those
are happening because that means there's
more and more stuff that i can just
interact with from ruby i don't have to
worry about creating my own HTTP request
to hit the rest endpoints for example
and I'm also just happy that we're
coming out with more examples the the
team here is working on lots of cool
tutorials on how to hook pieces together
we're doing more videos we're doing blog
posts we had a post on the open-source
blog earlier this year and we're just
trying to get more stuff out there to
get part of the community and I'm really
excited that as a rubios longtime rubios
that I can say hey check it out we've
got stuff for you yeah and there's stuff
coming from the community a couple
months ago there was an announcement
that someone had done Ruby tensorflow
bindings and that came completely from
the community and I was super excited
about that illegal and I i love my
community so much that i'm glad there's
stuff that they can use and like we have
all these cool things and you can use
them it's fantastic that's great you
touched on i think in an interesting
point there you're talking about
comparing providers yeah i think the
elephant in the room a little uh the
traditional i guess that might be the
right word people tend to go towards
Heroku why might they be interested in
going to Google cloud platform instead
so yeah I don't know if traditional is
the right thing but a lot of work with a
lot of boot camp students and a lot of
them learn rails because it's the
convention over configuration thing
makes it easy to learn for people who
don't have a ton of experience because
there is a right way and they often use
Heroku for their early for the early
deployments so Heric was great I've got
a lot of friends who work there it's got
a lot of great things about it I think
that our App Engine flexin Heroku are
slightly different in some ways App
Engine flex gives you a lot of options
about database layer for example you
have to pick you have to pick a database
layer and it also is based on container
image so you can actually see the whole
way down the container image is
available to the public you can see the
whole way down what we're doing heroic
who's got a lot of integrations they've
been around for a long time so there's a
lot of people who like their
integrations we also have integrations
with things like stock driver do the
monitoring and we have integrations with
our MLA api's we have integrations with
data store for example if you want to
know sequel solution
and so I think it's I always say those
when people ask me to compare providers
I get asked a lot it really depends on
your use case and stuff but you can
generally figure it out also our pricing
model is different and so that's another
thing that people should consider is
looking at how the pricing differs based
on what they think their use case is
going to be I know you were talking
about when we were talking before we
started recording about basically the
flexibility that having everything
running on docker containers also gives
you yeah so that's the other thing is I
like to talk about and I have not have a
talk half written but haven't gotten
accepted anywhere it's growing you're
growing your application on Google cloud
platform you start with of you know bare
minimum viable deployment you do it on
flex because it's easy and you can
iterate as quickly as you need to and
you don't have to worry about the
scaling because we'll take care of that
for you but then you realize you want to
move to a micro services architecture or
perhaps you want to do something
interesting with your database and so
you need to move part of it off and so
perhaps you move parts of it to Cooper
Nettie's because you have the container
image there and you can take it and you
can strip out the stuff you don't want
from our base container image and then
build your own or you can look at how we
did it and build your own based on that
and then eventually maybe there's pieces
that you just really need to do on a
plain old vm maybe you're doing some
crazy image processing or video
transcoding or something else that's
super compute intensive and it just
makes more sense cost wise or
performance wisely for you to do it
straight up on Google compute engine and
since you're already on our platform
your data is already there you've got
the project setup you've got the
permission set up it's really easy to
grow as your application grows on our
platform and whatever way you need to
and I think that's a huge advantage of
using a platform like ours where there's
so many products and so many ways to do
things is that we can meet you where
you're at wherever you are in your
product lifecycle so we interviewed some
time ago Russell Smith from as far as
brain for sqa and I think there was this
interesting thing where he was so
brilliant first QA runs a lot of things
on
heroku but they also access bigquery and
other technologies that are on google
cloud like i think that there's also
pretty interesting things like even if
you're running on Heroku can you use
things like I don't know like a stark
driver you can totally um stock driver
doesn't necessarily make as much sense
because work is a managed solution but
you could definitely use our MLA p is
very easily yeah you could use our big
queer is actually really popular it's
one of the things that I think got the
fastest adoption in the Ruby community
and I know I know a number of Ruby
companies that run rails that use
bigquery and it's been you can totally
use that from anywhere you just have to
put your data in it and streaming it
it's a gem you install it like any other
gem you create the object in you send
stuff to it it's fantastic it's two or
three lines of code I loved I love
simple I love easy and so yeah you can
even if you're running in another place
you can still use our tools where they
make sense if you're running on AWS you
can use all the stock driver tools yeah
because stack drivers cross cloud and
use the pieces that make sense we've got
a huge platform find the pieces that
make sense for you based on your
workload and where's the best place to
final information about all of this so
from the Ruby side cloud google.com /
Ruby we have a landing page we've got
tutorials quick starts links to the
libraries including links to our open
source libraries there and that's a
great place to go you can also go to the
general cloud page just to find out
about our products and since I know the
Ruby community in the DevOps community
actually have a fairly large overlap you
can also go to some of our monitoring
and logging pages to find out about
DevOps community and the reason for that
overlap for people who don't know is
that puppet and chef are written their
dsl is on top of Ruby and so there's a
lot of folks who worked on those tools
or have contributed to those tools who
are also rubyists we do also have a ruby
channel in the Google cloud platform
select community yes we do and the some
of the developers who work on our
libraries monitor it I was actually
checking it today and Mike was answering
questions someone had excellent now I
know also you just came back from Ruby
comp yeah I did Ruby comps this year was
last week and it was it was really good
it's one of my favorite conferences and
one of the most exciting parts was
hearing
bATS the creator of Ruby speak and he
was talking about how Ruby is becoming a
mature language I mean I got involved
back when it was I think Ruby 18 and
I've been through 19 and we're on to 23
at this point and the planning now is
going on for ruby three and there's a
lot of talk about how to support
concurrency well there's a lot of talk
about improving performance making ruby
three times faster and I'm glad that
those conversations are happening and
they're raising some interesting
questions about language design because
one of Ruby's guiding principles has
always been it needs to be easy and
delightful for the programmer but that
means that there's some stuff that maybe
isn't so easy or delightful for the
actual computer for example all the meta
programming that's really easy to do in
Ruby I was talking to someone today
about the fact that in rails you might
be debugging methods that don't exist on
in the source because they're
dynamically created at runtime and that
makes some things very hard and the so
talking about that and I'm really
excited where that's going I'm also it's
all so excited to see just who was there
there was a lot of folks they are
talking about application monitoring
about hosting a lot of interesting
things happening there was a great talk
on logic programming in Ruby some
fantastic talks about nurturing open
source communities and I helped out with
the Ruby and hardware track which was
just super cool lots of cool IOT stuff
including some stuff related to like our
machine learning platform where they
were doing voice recognition and
processing and I'll vision the someone
was trying to sew a little girl and her
dad Cora Clark and Jason Clark we did a
presentation where they had created a
chicken detector for their chicken coop
using a variety of pieces and it took a
picture every two minutes they could
figure out which other chickens were
laying eggs and which were their
chickens were not all that is awesome
yeah and and all that stuff all that
stuff is all these places all these I
owe to projects and stuff are also
places that some of our libraries could
come into play depending on what you
need to do ok so we are wrapping up here
we were running out of time just a
little bit is there anything we haven't
mentioned or anything you want to plug
or event you're going to be at or
anything really super cool and exciting
you want to mention
we haven't been a chance to I think I've
mentioned all the really super cool and
exciting stuff but if there any rubios
out there listening to the podcast if
you're going to be at railsconf I
promise we will be there we were there
last year we had a great time we're
going to be coming back next year and
you should totally come up and say hi to
us and if you ever see me at an event i
will give you a dinosaur sticker yes I
got a car sticker it is pretty awesome
they're pretty awesome I gotta say all
right great I just thank you so much for
joining us we really appreciate you
coming and spending time with us in this
wonderful gray room of podcast pneus
yeah thanks so much thank you guys for
having me this is always fun so thanks
so much to Asha for taking the time to
talk to us about Ruby and all the cool
things that are happening about the
language and the open source community
on Google cloud platform and now we are
going to talk about Cooper Nerys we have
our request of the week which is about
okay so I have imagined I have a
heterogeneous glasser oh you know you
have not all the machines are exactly
saying not all the note which are
exactly the same yep and let's say that
for instance some of the notes have SSD
oh and the others do not okay and I want
to run some of the containers that
require or that run better let's say on
sses so you want to say hey you know my
cluster is very big and I have a lot of
notes but whenever it is possible runs
these kind of pots yep on these kind of
note so something that's very disk i/o
heavy maybe is doing some data
processing yo are you ready for days
something let's imagine that you have a
GPUs for instance like you had a
reproduce on you want to do some
rendering so you want to make sure that
the container is running rendering run
on node with a GPU that makes sense how
would you do that with coronaries so
that's pretty cool so if anyone's done
anything with communities you're
probably familiar with how pods have
labels yeah man services are built on
top of those to say okay give me a
selector that i'm going to say with the
service i'm going to have a selector
that says i want to expose all the pods
that have these labels and so you've got
these laboratory key value pairs that
unit touch so communities kind of
extends that whole idea of key value
pairs with labels but rather than having
them on the pods you're able to add
labels to note
interesting so you could have like type
GPU or type SSD on nodes within your
cluster and you can add those as as you
see fit what's neat then is you have
this thing where you can have a node
selector in part of your pod
specification okay after you like your
your deployment or your replica set and
you can add a note selector that says
hey I want these only to run on these
nodes that have these key value pairs
these labels you have a selector cool
yeah I'm looking under the communication
now it it actually looks pretty simple
it's basically saying you know like I
just want these so it's it's it really
in the metadata of the pod when you're
describing it where you're going to say
something like I want the no definity is
gonna be something like run these on
something that has these values yeah so
in the in our case is in a node that has
one of the one of the labels is
something like GPU GPU something like
that you said an interesting word as
well like the basic version of node
selector is very simple it's like just
this this this combination of labels and
it's very interestin or like it's just
an and boolean but there is now for
feature of affinity which you said
before and also anti affinity which
gives you a lot more control and a lot
more complex label selection
capabilities as well so you can do
affinity like I want this running on
these machines you can do like preferred
affinity like it would be really great
if it did but if it doesn't that's fine
and then you can do the anti version of
that too so I don't want these running
here don't put these on these machines
or I'd rather not have this on these
machines that if there's any other
choice then I whatever exactly so that's
an alpha feature it's coming down the
pipeline but it looks like yeah you've
got a lot of control especially if ya if
you're running heterogeneous clusters
very cool well I think that answer the
question cool so why don't we talk real
quick about what are you going to be you
have to I'm not going anywhere so yeah
Thanksgiving that's coming up so you
have some time off we've got our team
off site so yeah things are wrapping
down for December just writing some
content and playing with some code and
building some fun things that I'll
probably talk about a little bit later
nice and yourself well I was planning on
working on just for fun Claude both of
my laptop's died
yesterday yeah so trying to fix that and
in the me was enjoying some holidays so
yeah very excited about our off-site in
two weeks in Los Angeles I don't know if
we're gonna maybe we should do an
episode about that yeah well we'll do
some recordings will see how they come
out cool awesome well thank you so much
for joining me yet again for a wonderful
episode Francis thank you Mark and thank
you all for listening and see you all
next week see you next week
[Music]
you
[Music]